THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE LEFT MOURNS THE LOSS OF A
MAGAZINE, LIKE THE LOSS OF A
FRIEND.
WE HAD SO MUCH QUALITY TIME
TOGETHER.
YOU UNDERSTOOD ME LIKE NO OTHER.
THE MOTIVATION TO SAVE THESE
OUTLETS AS POLITICAL AND
CULTURAL.
IF ONE MAGAZINE OR PUBLICATION,
NEWSPAPER IS ALLOWED TO DIE OFF,
THE REST MAY FOLLOW ALONG WITH
THEIR INFLUENCE.
ENTER "TIME" MAGAZINE.
BLEEDING CIRCULATION FOR YEARS
AND UNABLE TO TRANSLATE ITS
PRINT APPEALING TO THE INTERNET
AGE, TIME HAS GONE FROM A
CIRCULATION -- CHECK THIS OUT --
OF NEARLY 20 MILLION WORLDWIDE
TO JUST A FEW MILLION, PRIMARILY
WEB-BASED FOLKS.
THE ONLY THING KEEPING IT GOING
IS TWO FLAGSHIP OF THE PERSON OF
THE YEAR ISSUE COMES OUT IN
DECEMBER.
AND IT'S 100 MOST INFLUENTIAL
ISSUE.
THE LATTER WAS RELEASED WITH
P.R. TODAY WORTHY OF A QUEEN
STATE VISIT.
SPEAK OF THE MAGAZINE CREATED A
SPECIAL SERIES OF COVERS FOR THE
ISSUE, AND GRAMMY WINNER TAYLOR
SWIFT, THE HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI.
>> GAYLE KING WAS ALSO CHOSEN TO
GRACE THE COVER.
>> Laura: THAT IS ONE SUREFIRE
WAY OF GETTING YOUR MAGAZINE ON
THE NEWS.
PICK ONE OF YOUR ANCHORS.
ASIDE FROM THE INFLUENTIAL
FOLKS, BARR, MUELLER, AND TRUMP,
TIME INCLUDED A FEW OTHER
CURIOUS CHOICES LIKE KAVANAUGH
ACCUSER CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD
ABOUT THE PROFILE KAMALA HARRIS
WROTE HER STORY.
THROUGH HER COURAGE, SHE FORCED
THE COURAGE TO RECKON WITH AN
ISSUE THAT IS TOO OFTEN BEEN
IGNORED AND KEPT IN THE DARK.
TOTALLY POLEMICAL.
BUT CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD DID
LAST OCTOBER
WAS TO ACCUSE A MAN OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT 30 YEARS PRIOR
WITH ZERO CORROBORATION.
REMEMBER, SHE INITIALLY SENT AN
ANONYMOUS NOTE ACCUSING
KAVANAUGH WHICH WAS THEN LEAKED
TO "THE WASHINGTON POST."
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THIS ICON, AT
LEAST ACCORDING TO TIME, FAILED
TO DERAIL THE NOMINATION.
SO EXACTLY HOW IS THAT SO
INFLUENTIAL?
AS FOR TAYLOR SWIFT, I MEAN, SHE
CONTINUES TO BE AN ENTERTAINMENT
JUGGERNAUT, INCREDIBLY TALENTED.
HER BIG MOVE THIS PAST YEAR WAS
TO THROW IN WITH THE DEMOCRATS
AND ENDORSED MARSHA BLACKBURN
SENATE OPPONENT IN TENNESSEE.
WELL, BLACKBURN DECIDED TO SHAKE
HER OFF AND SHE WON.
NOT SO SWIFT PERHAPS TO THINK
YOUR POP MUSIC TRANSLATES INTO
ANY GREAT POLITICAL APPEAL.
AGAIN, RATHER THAN BE
INTROSPECTIVE ABOUT ITS LOSS OF
APPEAL IN MIDDLE AMERICA AND
BEYOND, "TIME" MAGAZINE JUST
KEEPS CLINGING TO THE OLD
LIBERAL MODEL OF JOURNALISM AND
OF COURSE CLINGS TO POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
>> WE HAVE 48 WOMEN ON THE LIST
THIS YEAR UP FROM 45 LAST YEAR.
WE STARTED DOING THIS IN 2004,
THERE WERE 24.
OBVIOUSLY STILL A WAYS TO GO IN
OUR SOCIETY.
THE LIST.
>> Laura: NO, NO, NO.
THE LIST IS NOT A REFLECTION OF
OUR SOCIETY.
THE REST OF SOCIETY DOESN'T
THROW ITSELF A GLAMOROUS PARTY
LIKE TIME DOES.
WHEN IT'S LOSING MONEY BY THE
MONTH.
SPEAKING OF GLAMOROUS, THE MODEL
AND WIFE OF JOHN LEGEND, CHRISSY
TEIGEN COMEAU WAS ALSO CHOSEN.
SHE'S KNOWN FOR HER VEST FISH
ATTACKS ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
CHOSEN ACCORDING TO THE PROFILE
BECAUSE, "ALL HER LIFE CHRISSY
TEIGEN HAS LIKED TO EAT.
SHE'S NOT SHY ABOUT THAT OR
ANYTHING ELSE REALLY."
WELL, THAT'S NICE AND INNOVATIVE
I GUESS.
EATING.
DID MOST AMERICANS LIKE HER TAKE
ON FEMALE EMPOWERMENT DURING
LAST WEEK'S DEMOCRAT RETREAT?
STEAK I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE TO
BE REALLY ANGRY ALL THE TIME.
>> IF THERE WAS ONE WORD YOU
WOULD HELP PARTICULARLY WOMEN
USE MORE FREQUENTLY, WHAT WITH
THAT ONE WORD?
>> [BLEEP]
YOU.
>> Laura: OH, OKAY.
THE BIG SHOCK THAT JOINING THE
TRUMP PAINTING MODEL ON THE LIST
IS A TRUMP HATING COMEDIAN.
TRUMP HATING FILMMAKER AND ERIC
TRUMP PAYDAY AND TV PRODUCER.
WELL.
AND FOR GOOD MEASURE, THEY THREW
IN MICHELLE OBAMA.
"TIME" MAGAZINE IS SORT OF THE
LAST GASP ALMANAC OF THE ELITE.
BUT AT LEAST THE ELITES DON'T
ADMIT DEFEAT EASILY, DO THEY?
YOU'VE GOT TO HAND OUT TO THEM.
THERE IS PERHAPS NO BETTER
EXAMPLE THAN HOW THEY'VE DEALT
WITH MUELLER IS NO COLLUSION AND
NO OBSTRUCTION FINDINGS.
>> THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION IN PLAIN SIGHT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CONDUCT THAT
RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
CRIMINALITY AND CONDUCT THAT IS
DEEPLY UNETHICAL, UNPATRIOTIC,
AND CORRUPT THAT MAY NOT BE
CRIMINAL.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD
RECUSE HIMSELF IMMEDIATELY.
HE HAS NO BUSINESS TOUCHING ANY
PART OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: OKAY, WELL, WITH
TOMORROW'S RELEASE OF THE
MUELLER REPORT MINUS REDACTIONS,
WE ARE BOUND TO SEE MORE
GYRATIONS FROM THE SAME
SUSPECTS.
FROM POLITICAL ACTIVISTS WHO
RAISED MILLIONS OFF THE CONSTANT
DEFAMATION THAT TRUMP WAS SOME
TYPE OF SELLOUT TO RUSSIA OR A
TRAITOR.
THEY MOVED BY THE WAY FROM HE
CONSPIRED WITH RUSSIANS
TO BARR IS JUST REDACTING STUFF
TO I DON'T KNOW, HELPED HIM.
>> THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO REASON
THAT THERE SHOULD BE REDACTIONS
FOR THE REPORT IS PROVIDED TO
CONGRESS.
>> OUR FIRST PRIORITY IS GETTING
THE FULLY UNREDACTED REPORT
BECAUSE THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
FINDINGS MAY NOT EVEN BE COVERED
IN THAT REPORT.
>> I THINK IT LEAVES A VERY
STRONG IMPRESSION ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THIS IS A
FORM OF POLITICAL EDITING THAT
IS TAKING PLACE.
>> Laura: WELL, IT AND
TONIGHT, THEY ARE GRASPING AT
SOMETHING NEW: THE TIMING OF
BILL BARR'S PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> IS THIS PRESS CONFERENCE AWAY
FIRST BARR TO GET OUT AHEAD OF
ANY INFORMATION THAT WE MIGHT
FIND IN THE REPORT AND PUT HIS
SPIN ON IT?
>> IF YOU WANT THE PUBLIC TO
TAKE THIS REPORT SERIOUSLY AND
BELIEVE THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS CREDIBLE, YOU'LL
PROBABLY THINK TWICE ABOUT
PUTTING THE HEAD OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OUT ON TV TO DO SPIN
FOR YOU.
>> HE BECOMES THE FIRST CABINET
SECRETARY TO PLUNGE INTO THE
DEEP END OF TRUMP'S CONSPIRACY
POOL.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF...
WE HAVE TRUMP FROM TRUMP IS
GUILTY OF SEDITION TO THE AG IS
GUILTY OF AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULING.
WHILE THEY WEIGHT FOR THE
REPORT, READ IT, AND THEN GREAT.
DECIDE IF YOU HAVE ISSUES WITH
IT AT THAT POINT.
IF THIS IS THE FREAK OUT
HAPPENING TONIGHT, I SHUDDER TO
EVEN THINK ABOUT WHAT WERE GOING
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TOMORROW.
WERE GONNA HAVE A GREAT SHOW ON
TAP.
THE MUELLER TEAM SPUN THEIR
WHEELS IN THE PROCESS AND WITH
END UP DOING IS THROWING A LOT
OF MODERATE GOOD PEOPLE.
SURE, THERE WERE INDICTMENTS IN
GUILTY BUT BETWEEN AG BAR AND
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ, WE MAY JUST FIND OUT
THAT THE SUPPOSE OF GUILTY
ONES WERE JUST DEEP STATE PONDS.
THE MUELLER APPROACH HAVE NEVER
BEEN STARTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE TOLD YOU THAT.
THEY WOULD FIND NOTHING ON THE
PRESIDENT AND THAT ITS ORIGINS
WERE POLITICALLY TAINTED.
AND WE WERE RIGHT.
AND THE LEFT WAS WRONG.
EVEN AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ADMITTING
THIS.
FOX NEWS WAS RIGHT AND THE
OTHERS WERE WRONG.
EVEN REGULAR VIEWERS OF CNN AND
MSNBC MUST CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
THE STRAWS BEING GRASPED OR
JUSTIFY STICKING WITH A
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT HAS BEEN
LARGELY DEBUNKED.
WELCOME OF COURSE THE HARD-CORE
SOCIALISTS AND THEIR MEDIA
COCONSPIRATORS WILL CLING TO THE
RUSSIAN DELUSION FOR AS LONG AS
THEY CAN.
OR SIMPLY SHIFT TO NEW TARGETS
WITHIN TRUMP WORLD.
THEY ARE SUCH ANTI-TRUMP
FANATICS THAT THEY CAN'T SEE
THAT THEY ARE COMMITTING ONGOING
SELF SABOTAGE TO THEMSELVES
PERSONALLY AND TO THEIR PARTY